es ist wie in einem schlechten
horrorfilm krebse mäuse ameisen fische
und wahrscheinlich auch menschen werden
durch parasiten und infektionen zu
zombies die den befehlen anderer
gehorchen walking dead in reality jetzt
in clixoom zahlen zum fiction
es ist das absolute horror szenario
durch eine fremde macht willen
losgeworden werden lebewesen zu zombies
die nur eines im sinn haben den virus
oder die parasiten von denen sie
befallen sind zu verbreiten
in der tierwelt gibt es dafür unzählige
beispiele laufen würmer oder viren
manipulieren ihre wirte und lassen sie
zu willenlosen robotern werden die juwel
wespe ist da noch ganz harmlos sie fällt
die drei mal so große amerikanische groß
aber an spritzt ihr gift in die brust
durch dass sie nicht mehr ihre beine
bewegen kann
danach wird die wespe extrem präzise und
spritzt mit ihrem stachel ihr gift in
eine ganz spezielle region des gehirns
die für die fluchtreaktion zuständig ist
ab sofort will die kakerlake alles nur
nicht mehr flüchten
das ist praktisch denn jetzt wird die
schafe zur schlachtbank geführt in eine
eigens dafür gedachte höhle die wespe
legt ihre eier ab verschließt die höhle
und wenn die larven beim schlüpfen dann
kommt das große finale aber dazu später
so wie bei der juwel weste geht es
ständig und noch viel perfider ab die
larven des baumes schießt du zehn fahrer
solidus etwa lassen sich im wasser von
ruderfußkrebse fressen im darm angelangt
bohren sie sich in den körper und
wachsen zu kleinen bandwürmern heran
der krebs wird ihnen aber schnell zu
klein jetzt muss er gefressen werden
damit sie weiter wachsen können
dafür machen sie den krebs zum zombie
und lassen ihn sich als futter anbieten
der krebs versteckt sich nicht mehr und
wird von einem stichling gefressen
ihr wiederholt er das verfahren wenn der
wurm groß genug ist steuert er den
stichlingen an die wasseroberfläche und
lässt ihn sich von einem vogel fressen
damen des vogels tat sich der wurm und
über den kot gelangen laufen wieder ins
wasser
und es gibt noch mehr beispiele seiten
würmer zwingen heuschrecken ins wasser
zu springen
obwohl sie nicht schwimmen können
parasiten befehlen ameisen auf grashalme
oder zwischen bären zu klettern und so
lange zu warten bis sie gefressen werden
sie steuern raupen in baumwipfel
verflüssigen sie dort und lassen sie
herunter tropfen pilze wachsen aus
ameisen köpfen und verbreiten von dort
aus ihre spur
uhren oder es gibt sogar eine wespenart
die legt eier in raub und ab die fressen
die raupen von innen auf aber nur fast
sie lebt noch so lange so dass sie die
verpufften westen fremd gesteuert als
zombie bewachen kann um dann nach dem
schlüpfen zu sterben
es ist wirklich wie in einem schlechten
horrorfilm und wir menschen sind
wahrscheinlich auch betroffen toxoplasma
gondii heißt der erreger der rund 60
prozent der menschen befallen hat und
womöglich steuert bewiesen ist ein
einfluss auf mäuse sie fürchten sich
dann nicht mehr vor katzen und werden
zutraulich die folge in nullkommanichts
sind sie katzenfutter und auch beim
menschen scheint sich durch den
parasiten einiges zu ändern der
tschechische evolutionsbiologe jaroslaw
leger hat tausende menschen untersucht
dabei kam verblüffendes heraus
toxoplasmose also die durch den
parasiten verursachte krankheit führt zu
langsame reaktionszeiten
das heißt der toxoplasmose hat baut
öfter einen unfall und bringt sich eher
selbst um das ist wirklich gespenstisch
eine dänische studie hat herausgefunden
dass frauen mit toxoplasmose er
selbstmord begehen
what the [ __ ] ein parasit steuert uns
aber warum restlos geklärt ist das noch
nicht vermutet wird dass wir in der
steinzeit so leichter opfer von
großkatzen wurden was meint ihr werden
wir vom parasiten fremdgesteuert ist so
etwas wie die zombie apokalypse denkbar
walking dead in real life diskutiertes
in den kommentaren die larven der juwel
weste sind übrigens nach zwei wochen
geschlüpft
erst haben sie die körperflüssigkeiten
der amerikanischen groß aber
aufgeschreckt und sich dann in ihren
körper gebohrt sie von innen
aufgefressen und sich dort dann verpackt
der kaka lager alles nicht viel
ausgemacht ihr fluchtreflex war
abgeschaltet da acs hat wohl oder übel
über sich ergehen lassen
mehr klicks um hier erfahrt ihr mehr
darüber wie ihr vielleicht demnächst in
den weltraum fliegen könnt links
übrigens auch immer in der video
beschreibung und tier geht es zum video
über die ebola epidemie übrigens
aktuelle news zum ebola ausbruch in
klick zum blog er oben mit jeder menge
wissenschafts news und nicht vergessen
ein abo auf youtube kostet nix also bis
dann bleibt brand